hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you
oh
[Music]
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing
there's an individual who continually
comes on to Patrick David's show
valuetainment
and speaks about Islam I don't
understand why he does this he's fixated
with the topic and I think he's actually
scared to engage with the Muslim
polemicist or an interlocutor on the
issues at hand because it keeps coming
on the show speaking about Islam using
challenging and polemical terms
antagonistic and pejorative language but
if you've got to do that why not
challenge yourself let's look at the
latest thing this guy has said and come
back and respond in kind one of the
reasons they tend to be a violent people
too is because their Prophet was a very
violent person Christ was not right
um not not to mention the Trinity they
believe in Allah there's a lot of
differences right as you can see here
the individual is falling into a range
of different fallacies and false
comparisons
the first thing I want to outline is the
following he makes a comparison between
the Prophet Muhammad
who we believe is the final Prophet sent
to all people and all times that he
affirmed the prophets that came before
him Abraham Moses Jesus Etc that he was
sent from God he made a comparison
between our Prophet Muhammad sallam and
Jesus Christ who Christian people
believe is God incarnate the question
first would be as follows why are you
comparing Prophet with God why not
compare god with God
the Christian people believe that Jesus
is God of course the Father the Son the
holy spirit that the father is God the
son is God the holy spirit is God but
they're not through God but one God that
contradiction aside the Christian people
believe that that Jesus is God the
Muslim people believe that Prophet
Muhammad is a prophet why compare god
with Prophet why not compare prophet and
Prophet why not compare Allah and The
Trinity that would be the fair
theological comparison
putting that to the side and for the
sake of argument I'll proceed anyway
the mistake you're making
my friend
is the following
you're saying that the prophet Muhammad
was a violent man
and that Jesus was a peaceful man
Jesus according to the New Testament
narrative was never giving political
power in fact he was whipped into
humiliation
so much so that Nietzsche himself was a
post-modernist atheist
described this as a kind of slavish
morality those who follow Christianity
is like slaves because they are
following a man who is meant to be God
who somehow humbled himself on the cross
and was pinned onto the to the crucifix
and said Eli Eli lemas oh God God why
have you forsaken me
he himself meant to be God
but the point is he was never given
political power whereas the prophet
Muhammad was given political power
so when the prophet Allah was given
political power even then
when he was conquering Mecca he came in
if you look at it's a Bedrock example
the the narration of how that happened
he was humble and he forgave the people
he forgave the people when it was in his
power to destroy everybody in that City
they surrendered they but he forgave
them he didn't destroy them and it was
in his power so thus you have a prophet
Muhammad
who in a situation where he could have
destroyed the people in the most uh in
the most grandiose
Conquest in his Reign and his
Premiership in his political Premiership
did not destroy the people in fact
forgave them Jesus Christ in this world
was humiliated beaten never given
political power in the next world as you
can see in the Book of Revelation
chapter 2 verse number 23 he not only
comes to avenge
uh all of these kind of violators but he
comes and kills the people as well who
does he kill if you look at the Book of
Revelation chapter 2 verse 23 you'll see
that he kills Jezebel The Prostitute and
her children
so look when Jesus is given according to
the biblical narrative political power
he goes and kills children and kills
prostitutes and kills women and children
where the Prophet salallahu told us not
to kill women and children in battle I
don't believe Jesus Christ because I
don't believe he would do such a thing I
don't believe Jesus Christ was a racist
as is mentioned in in the book in the
New Testament that he said he referred
to the Gentiles as the dogs and these
kind of things I don't believe the
depiction of Jesus Christ as a
humiliated racist uh coward effectively
who only destroys women and children
when he's given political power is a
correct one that is the depiction given
in the biblical text Muslims believe
that Jesus Christ was a true prophet of
God he was the Messiah chosen by God God
rescued him God protected him he was one
of the most honorable people on the face
of the Earth he was Jesus Son of Mary
who was a virgin who was given
Immaculate Conception yes and who cured
the blind with God's permission raised
the Dead with God's permission and did
all those wonderful things with God's
permission and that he was a prophet and
messenger yes tell me what of the two
depictions you think is more logically
coherent in sound which appeals to your
natural proclivities and instincts and
Common Sense
A or B that I've just mentioned but of
course this kind of conversation you
don't want to have and you couldn't have
and you wouldn't have because although
you respect you're a coward and I'm
going to say that very clearly I'm not
talking to Patrick because he's only
bringing him as a guest
but I'm speaking to them the guy himself
who keeps speaking pejoratively about
Islam and its texts and and the Muslim
people you are a coward yes because you
are speaking pejoratively about Islam
without the challenge of a Muslim person
being able to respond to you in kind I
have done so now the people have
listened you have been shamed
the prophet Muhammad
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a Sim at the house in
Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the message
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale